hello everyone good
afternoon I'm Gabor Chari I'm a software
engineer at
posit and I would like to welcome you to
the next session about compil link
design for apps
and
uh dashboards I guess
documents uh
please join me in welcoming our first
Speaker Laura
[Applause]
guest hello hello do I have a microphone
can you hear me are we good okay cool
all right so hi everyone uh my name is
Laura oh this is not the right slide
that's fun there we go okay there we go
um so my name is Laura Gast and um as a
compliment to the many how to build
beautiful things uh that you're hearing
ing at this at at this conference I want
to talk about why the design is worth
the time um specifically coming at it
from an angle of leveraging cognitive
science to amplify impact so I'm going
to step back for a quick second and to
start I want to explain where I'm coming
at where I'm coming from to get at this
presentation so um who am I um I do not
have formal design training what I have
done is I've worn many hats um I've
worked in ml image analysis I've worked
for political campaigns I've built
strategic plans for National malaria
elimination I've worked in National
Health insurances I've worked at the EOC
for covid and uh recently I work in
development for a military family
related NGO so I think many people in
this room have a similar weird winding
path through the world of data um and
the thing that my career has had in
common is a similar story that occurs
all the time and that's I have five
minutes to communicate three months of
work to a busy decision maker to get
them on side to to choose a path that we
think is has the most evidence behind it
so so let's talk about this
communication Okay who in the room has
heard a version of this sense the data
speaks for itself don't worry about
making it pretty has anybody yeah okay
pretty pretty good um so I am a firm
believer that the data can speak for
itself when the data collects itself and
the data cleans itself um in the
meantime uh you are the translator for
your data you speak for the data you
have to take the time to make it pretty
to give it a Fighting Chance right so
I'm not going to reveal anything
groundbreaking or revelatory today but
what I hope to do is give you a little
bit of that
semantic the semantics and the the
science to back up that feeling of like
I want to make it pretty I need to have
a little more time come on boss man give
me give me a couple hours to just make
this look a little bit better um so I'm
going to focus on three areas today um
there are many but these are the three
I've I've identified for today the first
is attention the second is memory and
the third is beauty so let's start with
attention and I Define that as making
them look where you want them to look
without them having a choice so we're
going to play a game I have a couple of
games just yell out answers when when
you got them so the first game is the
how many fives game uh Cole nuser nck is
I've seen leverage this game the best if
you need a primmer on how to do
storytelling like this her book is a
great entry point so so we're going to
play the how many FES game I'm going to
put a big wall in numbers up and as soon
as you count how many fives there are
yell it out okay ready here we
[Laughter]
go all right I have various numbers yeah
I think there's six um I might have I
don't know I seven okay um I'm going to
make one small change I'm going to
rearrange the numbers and make one small
change now do the same thing how many
fives are
there like I said none of this is is
groundbreaking you know this in your gut
but the science behind this all right so
the reason is that I'm leveraging
something called your sensory memory
that is the first second in which your
eyes glaze across something specifically
with this it's your iconic memory it's
the first couple of nanoseconds right
the first fraction of a second so it's
well beyond the scope of a short talk
you can Google it um sensory memory
right what's happening here is that
you're you're seeing this pattern of red
splotches before your brain can even
catch up to the fact that you're seeing
five of them or that they're the numeral
five the great thing about this is that
sensory memory is completely outside of
cognitive control and an automatic
response any person whose eyes glaze
over this screen will remember that
there were five red fives okay so color
is one factor we can use there are many
um I'm not going to talk through each of
these take a picture if you you need it
um but you all know all these without
having to think about it these are
inbuilt to the human brain right you
know length the longer something is the
more of the thing the size the width the
the the enclosure means they're grouped
together um if you want to get into
detail on these uh Cedric Sherer has a
ggplot to class he does before paa
conferences for the workshop time highly
recommend um so again none of these are
are groundbreaking um but they ensure
that your core idea is delivered to
those in your audience again without
having having that choice so couple more
games to drive home this point so just
shout out what you see first there are
no wrong answers all right
ready sun and I heard boat so the sun
obviously there you're leveraging the
color right maybe enclosure because
things are kind of leading toward it
position it's in the middle but I also
heard uh the boat and I heard a dock
over there and those are are larger
they're in the foreground right but most
people went to the sun right because
there's that difference all right here's
another one
a red train yeah so you might be seeing
different things here right there's
things that are competing for your
attention we're leveraging the color uh
the blue is brighter there's that there
there's Hue and color in there um when
they're competing things on a slide your
eyes ping ponging around because there's
competing pre-attentive attributes right
your eyes being tugged all right so let
me try another
one yeah okay so uh when there's just a
lot of stuff on a slide and you can't
focus on any one thing um we know from
ey tracking studies for marketing that
you're going to look either in an F
shape or a z shape that's what the human
eye is going to do in Western cultures
um so if my Prime image that I want to
draw your attention to is on the bottom
right I have to leverage one of these
attributes in order to make you look at
that thing first notice I haven't hidden
any of the data on this slide it's still
there I'm just using color in a targeted
way way right and using that that
attribute to draw your eye toward it
um sometimes it's
impossible um you have to use other
other tricks and tactics there are many
out there um but you know layers
Progressive disclosure which is showing
things at a time um sometimes it's hard
this is one of the coolest diagrams I've
ever seen it just takes you like 45
minutes to even see what's going on okay
so let's move on to the uh next item
memory which is I Define as keeping it
in their heads long after you've left
the room so we're going to step back
into cognitive science for a second and
we're going to talk about something
called cognitive load Theory big words
what it means is that our working memory
is limited uh in other words brains our
brains can only absorb so much
information when new ideas are shared or
presented to us this is why it's hard to
cram for an exam right this is why you
can't take a tutorial in r or Python and
know it all there there's only so much
we can absorb so it's broken down into
three categories the first is the
intrinsic load just inherently how
difficult is the thing beginners R is
way more easy than Advanced R 2 plus 2al
4 is way easier than differential
equations this is generally unchangeable
so we're going to talk about the other
two sections extraneous load how the
information is presented um you know
this is where you have the most control
as a presenter or creator of a dashboard
or a report um you know you tend to
think about this in data visualization
but also think about it in scaffolding
of literally how the information is
presented here we have the little r
Studio gooey right there's a scaffolding
there you know where to look for things
so it's easy to get to the information
to get to that new specific item um the
third part is the Germain load or
connecting the dots um broadly you can
think about this is the work that has to
be put in to permanently keep something
in your head um think about like
literally connecting the dots like data
storytelling or analogies right you're
connecting it to something that's
already in your brain again this is this
is a light l
LEL it yeah I'm keeping this simple um
so your goal is to make sure that you're
maximizing the things that need to be
maximized and minimizing the things that
need to be minimized intrinsic load
locked fairly unchangeable um you want
to minimize distraction turn down that
extraneous load and turn up the germine
load maximize that story so that they
learn it and it stays there
so how again you know these things uh
you can think about heat Maps you've
minimized that distraction you haven't
put that wall of numbers in and you're
focusing in on that story about where
are those colors the scaffolding is
known it's a square things go across you
can also think about this in the terms
of schematics right there's a
scaffolding there there's a layout
there's a flow you're trying to guide
people through information um but
sometimes you need to make choices this
is from Alberto Cairo um and this is
covid information by County the colors
County um depending on on what you want
to communicate there's a better or a
worse way to do it is time the thing
you're talking about or is the county
the thing you're talking about um and
when you think about all these things in
concert this is why maps are so
effective right so think about
everything that's encoded in here we
effectively have a heat map
concentration right the colors are um
census uh census group types um so you
can see there's density so that's that
heat map you have the organization of
the schematic of the map north south
east West you know the water the sh the
coastline of Chicago um you can
emphasize the story you want to tell
with these these various choices so this
would take dozens of tables to walk
someone through to get what all of your
brains are getting in an instant by the
way I've organized that information
through careful design
choice I don't want you to just think of
this in terms of data visualization I
also want you to think about this in
terms of the fonts you pick so this is
one of my favorite studies it's from
2008 I'm sure there have been repeats
that find the same thing but I love this
so uh this study found that people are
more likely to engage in a given
Behavior the less effort it requires not
ground not groundbreaking pretty pretty
standard human they gave uh an exercise
regimen to two groups of people the only
thing they changed was the font that's
an aerial the clean looking aerial and
then a brush script all right and they
asked the people there were five metrics
they were tracking the first was how
hard do you think this is going to be to
complete how long do you think it will
take you then they were asked to
complete the exercise and then how long
did it take them and uh how hard was it
every single one of those metrics was
worse simply by changing the script they
estimated that it took almost double the
amount of time only because of brush
script right so this slight increase in
cognitive load made people think this
was harder if it's hard to read it's
hard to do so it's not just data viz
it's also the fonts you choose how do
you how do you break this apart all
right let's go to this third point and
I'm going to bring it all together so
the third point is beauty very
subjective I'm aware um so I'm defining
this as making people want to engage
more often or more deeply so I'm going
to tell you a story from this book about
this soap this is a great book if you
like design um so this is the method
brand soap so uh when they were creating
this this brand of soap this new soap
they wanted to design something that
looked beautiful on your countertop
people were tired of those ugly soap
containers they just they weird little
lid and they didn't look pretty and they
wanted to design something that looked
good on the countertop so they designed
this they sent it out to a whole bunch
of people asked them their
feedback the problem was is that they
hadn't managed to master the little lid
thing that sits upside down and these
things leaked all over the
countertop they still found that their
test groups wanted to buy this soap over
their competitor even though it leaked
on their countertop because it looked
better on their countertop top right so
you know aesthetic designs in general
look easier to use and have a higher
probability of being used whether or not
they're actually easier to use it's it's
not groundbreaking but it's it's I find
it incredibly interesting so Beauty
subjective but the results are objective
right so if you think something's pretty
it's going to elicit a positive emotion
in your brain and they do this by fmri
mapping they do all this crazy stuff but
when you can find a positive emotion um
you information is processed more
quickly information is remembered longer
and the uh credibility and trustworthy
trustworthiness you perceive those both
to be higher so this all comes from
positive emotions I think everybody in
here has a favorite weather app on their
phone that they like better than all the
other weather apps the information is
exactly the same but you like one better
because it's designed in a way that is
pleasing to you um we've all seen those
um like terrible news or news pages that
have like ads everywhere and like
flashing things and all this stuff it
doesn't feel true something about it
feels like they're lying to you um so
you prefer the one that's that's cleaner
and less in your face right so it
somehow feels more true even though it's
exactly the same information so let's
bring this all back together somewhere
where we all kind of feel comfortable
vignettes right this is not where you
think about when you think about
beautiful design simple vignettes but
think about how this is working with
attention right the use of color right
so I'm using the blue to show you where
links are um the use of the white space
the little icon the ggplot hex sticker
hex logo right um that is that is
connected in your head so that you
remember things we're using these clean
sansera fonts like that exercise regimen
study um there's a standard layout for
all of these when you're going to a
package that you've never seen before
you know if you click on the reference
you click on the Articles you know how
it's going to be laid out and there's
literally links Galore connecting
everything to everything else so you
know where you're going and it also just
feels better somehow than the the
standard
documentation um I don't know
why it just feels it's the same
information it just feels better um and
again you know there there's it's a
sarap Fant and a Sandara Fant it's a
less friendly feel there's not as much
color the layout's clunkier you can
still navigate around
but you don't want to play with it you
want to play with the the vignettes
right you want to want to experience
them um so you know I at the end of the
day you want to leverage these three
items any more but these are three good
core ones to start with your attention
make them look where you want them to
look memory keep it in their heads for a
long time by making it easy for them to
keep it in their heads and then Beauty
if if you think it's looks really good
and friendly and you're happy with it
odds are other people are going to too
we're all humans we all have human
brains we're kind of going in the same
direction so at the end of the day you
speak for the data uh you can back it up
get yourself a little time to make it
pretty thank
you thank you we have time for questions
you can still ask questions on slido one
question I have uh so as a data
scientist what are some good ways to
start thinking about design and
improving you know the design of your
work yeah I I think one of the great
ways is working I think the easiest
Avenue in is theming right we want to
work with our like corporate colors or
your team colors so if you you bring
that idea of an identity together you're
relying on other people to to get that
scaffolding together right so we have
the same colors we have the same fonts
so that's one way to start that's an
easy Avenue the other part is I do this
a lot is I find someone who doesn't know
anything I'm talking about and give them
my presentation my dashboard my report
and ask them what do you get out of this
tell me what you get you don't write any
code but tell me what you get out of
this and they're going to find five
points for me and some of them I'm like
yes I wanted you to focus on that and
some of them they like what are you
talking about and so that can help guide
me toward okay well I'm not hitting this
point correctly I need to work here um
and and working in that feedback loop
hope that's
helpful yeah that's very helpful another
question is any sense yet for how these
principles can transfer over for people
with visual
disabilities um I am not an expert in in
in that area um but I do really
appreciate the um there are a lot of
websites out there I use the Adobe site
um but there are a number of places
where you can put whatever you're
designing into these to show what it
looks like with color blindness and so a
lot of the times you know we'll want to
use the default blue scale something but
if you push it into that you'll see that
maybe someone with color blindness isn't
seeing the same thing right and so
that's when you need to leverage those
other preattentive attributes size
length enclosure um some rely on color
blindness or uh rely on color where it
makes it difficult for colorblind
individuals some rely on enclosures and
then at the same time for those that are
visually impaired you always need to
talk through if you're giving a a
presentation like this you need to guide
people around what you're talking about
so if they can't see anything they're at
least following
along right right next question
how do you give critical design
feedback cautiously um is the is the
right way um usually when I I I do a lot
of this feedback for people in my
organizations and usually I start by
asking what do you want to tell me um
and you'll get that elevator pitch out
of them or they'll ramble around in
circles about well we tried to do a
thing and then the thing didn't work and
then that other thing and then we tried
this model but that model was too
difficult so we moved to this model and
I said okay who Are you delivering this
to analysts or the SE Suite if it's the
SE Suite they just want to know your
model worked most of the time if it's
the analyst they want to know what
models worked and didn't work and so you
need to make sure
that synthesizing into the one point
that you're trying to make and then
going from there rather than saying I
have all this information and I need to
bring it down so starting starting from
that core point and and branching up
from there is tends to be the way I
direct
people question from Anonymous
importantly what should I do if my
Corporation has a terrible color
branding
scream quit no I'm just kidding um um
I've worked with our brand Team to try
and develop sort of alternate colors
that I can use in reports um our
standard color palette is not great for
color blindness and we have red and blue
and they like everything has to be in
our red white and blue color scheme and
I'm like well now everything that's red
is important right and so I've tried to
be like okay well what greens can we use
that aren't related to our color palette
and I've worked with that Design Group
and they trust me and again these are
mostly internal documents so I don't
need to adhere to our theme in the world
um but again collaboration is the is the
key to the key to the game and then also
you know you've got a brand book so pick
some of the other colors you
know work ways to work around it thank
you thank
you and let's let's welcome our next
speakers Aaron Chaffetz and karish